This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
for post-docctorates and pathology,
naturopathic doctor,
you
>> Hello. Hello everybody and welcome to
Daily with Doc and Becca. And you know
what day it is? Is it's Friday. Well, it
is pharmacist Friday here on Daily with
Doc. And I'm excited to have you joining
us as we've got a lot that we're going
to be covering, especially
if you feel like your body's broken.
It's not. So if you were invited to this
program by somebody specific, make sure
that you get back with them as they
cared enough about you care enough to
say thank you. This program is being
sponsored by dailywithdoc.com
where you'll find great information.
Make sure that you go there
dailywithdoc.com.
Sign up for the email list. And if you
are interested in following us on any
platform, all you have to do is do daily
with Doc and Becca in any browser and
it's going to come up with all the
different platforms that we are featured
on. So, make sure you follow us, make
sure you like us, send us some love, and
if you are watching now, put in the
comments where you're joining us from.
If you're here live with us, because we
do do these recordings live,
there's a chat. Make sure that it's open
as Phyllis is going to be putting more
information to help you take notes in
the chat. As also let us know where
you're joining us from. Yeah, joining us
from if you're here live with us. Now,
my name is Becca Dukes. I'm a certified
holistic health coach and a certified
naturopathic
>> natural article makes LDL sticky.
someone
>> who
somebody needs to mute. Um and
um and it's my honor and privilege to be
able to provide as a resource to an
amazing community information that is
empowering helping you as coaches and
you as an empowered individual no matter
where you are in this great beautiful
world to take better control of your own
health and things that you can do right
now at any moment. So, without any
further ado, if you've ever wondered if
your symptoms are actually trying to
tell you something, in a world where
we're often taught to silence discomfort
as soon as possible, pharmacist Bin
brings a different perspective. If you
think that your body is broken, well,
it's not. It's talking to you. In
today's conversation, we'll explore the
powerful idea that symptoms are
messages, not necessarily enemies. We'll
discuss how pain medications work,
important questions to ask before taking
them, and common medication
considerations that every patient should
understand. And I can't think of a
better person to help me cover these
things than the one and only a voice in
the natural world who is very
wellresected
my friend my mentor pharmacist Ben
Buuches. Hello pharmacist.
>> Hi there. Hi there. How are you?
>> I'm good. Thank you. So isn't that in
your opinion as a lay person? I mean, I
have my opinion as a health care
professional, but as a lay person, isn't
it obvious that your symptoms are
telling you something?
>> Well, you know, for for me, yes.
But I remember my symptoms being so bad,
I just wanted them gone.
>> Yeah. Oh, that's true, too. And and
that's a very good point. But it seems
kind of obvious that your symptoms are
telling you something. The question is
is what counts as a symptom versus the
disease?
Mhm.
>> Like is a disease separate from the
symptoms?
>> Is there something is there something
called a disease without a symptom?
>> Uh no.
>> Is there something?
>> That's right. So, you know, we want to
we focus on the signs rather than the
problem. And we assume the signs of the
problem like you say, understandably,
because if you have pain or headaches or
movement disorders or memory problems,
whatever, those are symptoms. And
sometimes it's understandable. We say,
"I don't care about the cause. I just
want to get rid of the symptom."
and and we have a we've created an
entire institution that serves that need
to get rid of the symptom. So it's very
glib to say you know let's get rid of
the disease
and don't worry about the symptom
because sometimes getting rid of the
disease or getting rid of the biochem I
don't want to say disease getting rid of
the biochemistry that's causing the
problem there's some there's a time lag
you go into and to give you an example
you go into the doctor you have this
incredible searing pain in your abdomen
from a gall from a gall stone right
>> do you want to work on your digestive
system and take your digestive enzymes
and change the way you eat and do all
the things you need to do to to prevent
stone formation or you just want to get
rid of that stone.
>> Well, for Mrs. Ben, people don't
understand that it is what they're
eating that caused that stone. They just
want
understanding.
>> Well, even if I told you if you came in,
if I was your doctor and you came in and
you had this searing, burning, agonizing
pain in your abdomen from a gallbladder
and I said to you, "That's your
digestive system. You must be eating the
wrong food. I want you to start changing
the way you eat and then maybe start
using some ultimate enzymes and then
maybe take some apple cider. You know,
if I explain the whole mechanism to you,
your response justifiably would be, I
don't care. Get rid of this pain. And
that's really the issue is, you know,
when we have a symptom, often times, not
always, but oftentimes we don't care
about the cause. We just want to get rid
of the symptom. Now, that depends, of
course, on the the sever degree of
severity of the symptom. you have
something like high blood pressure
that's different than a kidney stone or
a gall stone. But nonetheless, there's a
time where a time is reached where
sometimes where we don't care about the
cause. We just want to we just want to
get rid of the whatever that symptom is.
But here's the problem. The Hang on, let
me finish real quick. Here's the
problem. The symptom will continue. The
the problem will continue. You're not
going to take care of the issue. OMIC,
perfect example. you know, we go via
those GLP-1 drugs. Yes, you'll lose
weight. And now you're starting to see
literature that talks about how, oh,
people on GLP-1s, they have lower rates
of infertility, they have lower rates of
heart attacks, they have, you know, they
have lower rates of fatty liver,
whatever, because they're they're
changing the way their body handles
sugar. However, however, you're still
eating. You're still going to have the
same biochemical biochemical issues that
you that caused the problem in the first
place. You haven't really fixed that.
You're still going to have intestinal
and this is where the side effects come
from because you haven't really fixed
the problem. All you've done is modify
the symptom. Why is your insulin why is
your insulin up? Why is your um why is
your blood sugar up? Whatever it is
that's causing the problem, you've
artificially
disguised it. you've changed the the way
the body manifests the symptom, but you
haven't changed the problem. How your
body handles sugar, for example, how
your pancreas is functioning or your
intestine or your bile or your
gallbladder, whatever it is. So, there's
nothing really, you know, it it's
logical. It makes sense to want to take
get rid of the symptom and the medical
model serves that logic, but it doesn't
take care of the problem. And that's
what we're here to do. The whole model
of nutrition and naturopath naturopathy
and lifestyle med lifestyle um
strategies is to address the problem.
Once you're at the point where you have
a severe symptom, understandably, you're
going to want to get rid of it, but you
don't want to get to that point. So,
before you have a gall stone, you're
probably going to have some digestive
issues. You're probably going to have a
little bloating, maybe some diarrhea or
constipation. You're going to have gas.
You're going to have discomfort. That's
where you want to start to address the
cause. By the time you get into
gallstones or kidney stones,
understandably, you don't care. You
don't want to get to that point. And
that's that's the message. And like you
say, every single symptom we call
symptoms, the name, the word symptom is
a a uh your body's cry for help.
everything. Even if it's a mild one,
even it's just a rash or even just
problems sleeping or or um you know,
memory problems, even the mild benign
symptoms, they're your body telling you
something. And the smart thing to do
when your body's telling you something
is ask what your body's telling you.
Just like a baby, and I always like this
analogy, your body is your baby. There's
a you and there's your and then there's
your baby or your body. And our job is
to take care of the baby. Yes, you can
tape your baby's mouth shut if he's
crying. You don't have to hear him. You
can poison your baby with a, you know,
some kind of Xanax or chloral hydrate or
some kind of drug. Yes, you could do
that. And, you know, you could
surgically remove the baby's vocal
cords. And that's really metaphorically
exactly what we do when we take the
gallbladder out. We medicate to lower
blood pressure, for example, um or when
we do an ablative therapy. We're taping
our baby's mouth shut. We're drugging
our baby. We're surgically removing our
baby's vocal cords. And when I put it
that way, doesn't that sound crazy?
>> Like you would never you would never
think of doing that.
>> Yeah. You would never think of doing
that with your baby. But yet, because we
don't see the body as our baby, we think
it's fine to do to the body. We're
missing opportunities and we're missing
opportunities to extend our life. And
remember, while a drug may hide or mask
or prevent or reduce the incidence of a
symptom, there's a cost to that drug.
You're going to be losing nutrients that
are responsible for perhaps whatever
you're taking the drug for in the first
place or responsible for for um
preventing what you're taking the drug
for the first place. I was just reading
yesterday about how um statin drugs,
which are not the worst, you know,
they're not the most potent powerful
drugs there are. They're relatively mild
compared to to most drugs, they will
impair cardiac mitochondria.
Mitochondria depend on co-enzyme Q10.
Yeah, that whole electron transport
thing that we talked about a couple of
weeks ago, that all depends partially on
co-enzyme Q10, which statin drugs
deplete.
So, you know, you can see the craziness
of it. You're you're c the drugs are
costing you nutrients that would be used
by your body to address whatever it is
you took the drugs for, whatever it is
you're taking the drugs for.
>> So, many people come to us when they've
already got all of these different
symptoms. They've already received a
label from their doctor, which I
encourage you, don't accept labels,
and they want instant results.
But what we offer
is the ability to, yeah, they may get
the results and the instant results, but
why would you get an instant result that
then is going to reoccur, reoccur,
reoccur? And that's part of what we do
is we help educate people so they don't
have to go through that reoccurring
pain.
>> And that's you said the key word right
there. This is not just about giving
people nutritional supplements. This is
about helping people understand why
their nutritional supplements are
working, why their symptoms are showing
up, why their drugs are having an
impact, positive or negative, on their
body, how everything's working. And you
don't want to get to that point. By the
way, this is, you know, we focus and
it's understandable. We we talk to
people who are unhealthy a lot and
people ask questions about their health
issues, this that and the other, but we
don't want to wait until we're running
into a health challenge for us to get
into a nutritional supplementation
program. So, the real idea, there's two
ideas here. Number one is the idea that
yes, your health challenges can improve
with the healthy star pack, with Beyond
Tangy Tangerine, with the Daily Digest,
with the nightly successes
can improve with that. But the second
element is you want to be loaded up with
nutrients ahead of time so you don't
have to run into the problem in the
first place. And so healthy people need
to be listening to this message, not
just sick people. Healthy people need to
supplement. Young people need to
supplement. People who have who who for
whom disease and aging is not on the
radar, they need to be putting uh making
sure that they're uh improving their
nutritional status and mega dosing on
nutrients. so they don't get to that
point. And we really want to talk to
people who are healthy, not just people
who are sick. We want to talk to people
who are healthy so they stay healthy.
People are young so that they they they
age much more gracefully and slowly
rather than wait until you've got, you
know, six different health challenges.
You're on multiple drugs and you've got
your organs taken out and you know, it's
a lot harder to deal with things then.
Not that it can't be done. It can always
be you can always make someone feel
better with nutritional supplementation
if they're not already on a nutritional
supplementation program. But I want to
focus on I want people who are healthy
to focus on um the importance of
lifestyle strategies and nutritional
supplementation programs.
>> Well, pharmacist Ben, I have a
distributor who is actually a business
owner. He owns a couple different
businesses and a part of his health plan
for his employees is he has agreed to
cover a certain dollar amount of their
program
to help them stay healthy.
Well, there's been a couple of them that
I've we've gotten together, we've done
an evaluation, we've got them on a
program, and this week, one of the uh
individuals
had mentioned, you know, I went into
this totally skeptical, not expecting
anything to happen.
And I'm like, yeah, most of us do.
And the response was, I feel so much
better
just in the last three weeks of doing
this program.
I'm amazed.
And I mean, this individual had a whole
grocery list of symptoms.
>> And this is a person this is a person
who was not who never supplemented.
>> Well, no, they were supplementing. Then
they were supplementing like what
incorrectly or
>> they were doing fractionation.
>> Just fractionating.
>> What is I don't know what that means.
What does that mean? Fraction.
>> That means taking taking kind of like
you do with a pharmaceutical. This for
that this for that you know this doctor
says
>> they wanted an overall on an overall
program.
>> They were not on an overall program and
we got them on an overall program and it
changed their life. It's, you know, it
almost sounds hyper,
>> it almost sounds hyperbolic and like
you're exaggerating, but that's exactly
right. When you've not been on a
supplement program or you're not
supplementing strategically, and
strategy is really important when it
comes to supplementation because you
know the the when I started doing this
30 years ago, 35 years ago, there's not
a lot of information out there. Today,
there's a ton of information, but that
could be a problem because people are
taking this this supplement, this
formula, this remedy. They're kind of
kind of cobbling together a supplement
program based on what this guy told
them, this health this health
practitioner told them, their friend
told them, what's on the what they
happen to read on a blog or on the
internet, and they're kind of cobbling
together a quilting together a a
mishmash, a hodgepodge of different
supplements. You want to have a
strategy. And that's what I always tell
people when they when they tell me about
supplementation is what are we trying to
achieve here? And then based on what
we're trying to achieve, you put
together a program that is strategic
that involves all the different systems
that is uh involves the water soluble
nutrients, the fat soluble nutrients and
it's all put together in this kind of
strategy and that's what you guys are
teaching I presumably in your u with
your with the holistic health coach
program. But the point I want to make
is, and I want everybody to hear this
because I know it in our our crazy
hyperbolic world where everybody
exaggerates and everybody talks about
how wonderful their products are, the
revolutionary nature of a supple of the
intake of a nutritional supplement
program when you have never been on one
or you've been on one, haven't been on
one strategically, is miraculous.
It is so transformative and
life-changing. And all you got to do is
talk to people on this call who are
doing this call like yourself, Rebecca
or Ruth Ellen or AJ or Albert or Phyllis
who've experienced this and have
witnessed this in other people. It's
absolutely mindblowing what a
nutritional supplement program can do.
And particularly when you haven't been
on a nutritional supplement program,
when you haven't if you haven't
supplemented before and you have high
blood pressure, cardiovascular health
issues, digestive problems, whatever it
is, and you never supplemented before,
I'm talking to people have not
supplemented. And this is still the vast
majority of Americans, by the way, and
this is our um this is our uh our
audience. These are the people who we
should be talking to and communicating
with. When you haven't supplemented and
then you put supplements in the system,
it's in beyond incredible. all of a
sudden your body has these raw materials
that for some people for a lifetime they
haven't had. And so that's why I always
tell people just try the Beyond Tangy
Tangerine. It'll cost you 60 or 70 bucks
for a jar. It's the transformative
nature of it can't even be expressed in
words. Even something like the the
mineral Todd just the just the planter
minerals drink which is like 40 bucks.
Even for even that alone,
>> what's that
It's actually only 35 bucks
shipped to your door.
>> That's crazy. There's no reason not to
be on that for $35, especially if you've
never been on a supplement program.
>> Well, and I'd like to speak to those who
have been on a supplement program
because pharmacist Ben, when I found Dr.
While I had been taking supplements for
more than a decade
>> and I was still not feeling great. I
felt like I was getting sicker and
sicker. So if you're on a program where
you don't feel a difference, your body
is not absorbing what you're getting
>> or it's in the wrong ratios.
So that's one thing that I felt right
away with the Youngevity products. I
mean, I had been dealing with migraine
since I was eight years old. I found
longevity when I was 43,
44.
>> Wow. Wow. Wow.
>> And within two weeks, that was the first
thing that was gone. And in 10 years,
I've had
maybe seven headaches that were close to
migraine, but nothing like I experienced
day in and day out before.
>> That's awesome. So, it's, you know, not
all supplements are created the same.
And that's one thing that I absolutely
love about what Dr. Wallick and the team
has done in putting together the
programs we offer. It's changed my life.
So, I have a question for you,
Pharmacist Ben.
>> Yes.
And folks, if you're watching and
listening and you have a way to to uh
type a comment or question, I want to
know what symptom confuses you most
about what you're experiencing.
>> You're talking to me?
>> No, this is for everybody.
>> Oh, okay. Gotcha. Gotcha.
>> My question for you
is, can nutrients and medication
coexist?
that I know you're just kind of you just
want me to say it because we say it all
the time. Not only can they coexist.
Well, two things. Not only can they
coexist, but as I've said many times, I
want everybody to hear this because it's
really important and you can take this
to your medical professional. Nutrients
help your drugs work better. Nutrients
will make your drugs work better and
they'll also help you detoxify. And make
no mistake about it, drugs need to be
detoxified. They need to be purified.
your nutrients will help your drugs work
better and they'll support bodily
detoxification. And so you really want
to get that I that kind of idea in your
head that when your body is stronger
from nutrition, it's going to respond to
medication more appropriately. Second
thing I want to say about that is
there's this idea that the medical folks
have that nutrients are like drugs. They
see all interventions
into the body. By interventions I mean
you put something into your body to take
care to to to do some therapy on
something therapeutic interventions
>> the same.
>> So they see taking vitamin C for a cold
like the same way as taking antibiotics
for they see taking zinc for acne the
same way they see taking um tetracyc for
acne. they see taking a u vitamin K for
your bones or for uh blood for for your
blood or for calcium metabolism whatever
the same way they see blood thinners or
blood or anti uh blood thinning
medication or um or blood we'll say
blood thinning medication here's where
it becomes important first of all it's
not the same when we say vitamin K helps
with blood clotting that doesn't mean it
makes the blood clot say that again when
we Say vitamin K helps with blood
facilitates blood clotting. It doesn't
make
the blood clot.
A drug makes
makes makes
the blood clot or thin or whatever. A
drug makes
a nutrient sets the environment up so
that the body can do what it needs to
do. Is that is that clear? There's that.
That's a kind of a subtle distinction,
but it's very important. A nutrient
gives the body what it needs. So, it can
go yay or nay. It can say yes, I'm going
to clot. Yes, I'm no, I'm not going to
clot. But it gives the body the options.
A drug says clot. And the physicians,
the medical model, they don't make a
distin distinction. So, when we say
vitamin K clots the blood, that's not
true. Vitamin K provides the body what
it needs to clot the blood. And that's
vitamin K is is the big one because
that's doctors have it in their head
that it's involved with blood clotting
and blood thinning and blood clotting
are very important probably the most
important biochemical processes there
are is the viscosity of the blood as
we've talked about many times. So not
only do nutrients help your drugs work
better
but nutrients
have to be regarded
in a different way as drugs because they
just set the table. They don't
they they're not the they're not the
meal. They're just setting the table.
It's a that's a good metaphor. They're
not they're not doing the work. They're
allowing the body to decide if it wants
to do the work. And then, and this is
really important,
vitamin K is involved in I'm just using
this example. It could do anything in a
lot of other things. So, when a doctor
says not to take vitamin K because I'm
giving you a blood thinner and vitamin K
will clot your blood. Now he's depriving
your body of a very critical nutrient
for wound healing or for calcium
metabolism or for bone strength and
connective tissue strength.
Nutrients set the table or or uh help
facilitate biochemistry in the body for
lots of things. So when you tell
somebody not to take a nutrient, not
only you're going to stop uh that
particular process that you're concerned
about the blood, the fluidity of the
blood, but all the other functions that
that uh that that nutrient is involved
with are going to be compromised. It's
just crazy.
Not illogical
uh illogical biochemical bio uh u
biochemistry,
but we have to understand that's how
they think. They're not bad people.
They're not stupid people. They're not
trying to hurt anybody. That's just
their mindset. And guess what?
We went to them. They didn't come to
you. We went to them. So when you go to
them and then they give you their logic
based on what they've been taught and
based on what they believe and based on
what they've been told, you can't argue.
You went to them. And so that's that's
their opinion and you're getting their
opinion. They're not going to give you
my opinion. They're not going to give
you Doc's opinion. They're going to give
you their opinion. So, if you go to
them, just understand that's how they
think. That doesn't mean it's correct,
but that's how they think. And that's
why personally I would avoid going to a
physician unless an emergency
or if you maybe needed some check if you
you just want to be have some kind of,
you know, some metrics done, some bio,
some some testing done. But other than
that, a doctor's not going to help you
with your diabetes.
He's not going to help you with your
digestive problems. I mean, he may help
the symptoms,
you know, he's not going to help you
with your movement disorders, your
Alzheimer's disease, your dementias,
your Parkinson's, whatever. They don't
have tools for that. Why is it that we
don't see they don't have tools for
that? That's not their skill set. That's
not their wheelhouse. They're there to
repair, to fix, and they're good at it.
They're really good at it. And so as
long as long as we continue to
participate with the medical model for
life for what we should be taking care
of ourselves via lifestyle, you know,
that's what we're going to be dealing
with. And you can't complain because we
go to them.
>> Well, we do go to them thinking that
they know it all. But they get very
little
nutrition.
>> They know it. They don't know it all.
You get the distinction. They know what
they know what they study. They don't
know it all. Absolutely not. And you
know what? They'll admit it. Most most
physicians will admit it. I I have a I
don't even know how many friends I have
who are physicians. 20 25 friends who
are physicians. They all they're not,
you know, they're not self-righteous
about things. They admit it. They said
we don't know.
But in out of an abundance of caution,
number one, caution for their patients
and then caution for themselves because
there's standards of care. There's legal
reasons why they have to put you on a
statin drug if your cholesterol is high
or your uh a blood pressure medicine if
your blood pressure is high. There's
legal reasons for that. Remember, we're
going to them. So, they're going to
operate with their rules. We got to play
by their rules. So, if you have high
blood pressure, if you have memory
problems, if you have high blood sugar
or or you're gaining weight or whatever
it is, take care of your own business.
And that's really the issue. And that's
why Youngevity is so so powerful is
because we allow we give you the tools
to so that you can take care of your own
business. Now, guess what? Not everybody
wants to do that. And Youngevity is not
for everybody. Young, as any distributor
will tell you, it's not for everybody.
We get people who say, "No, no, I don't
believe you. I that's not what my doctor
told me. I I heard something different
on the news, blah, blah, blah." Fine.
Those aren't our patients. Those are our
customers. Those are our clients. the
ones who are suspicious,
the one and this is one thing by the way
that I found and I've been doing Younge
longevity now for 30 years almost. The
one thing I found the the one thread
that runs through um all of the people
that I've known in Youn
and distributors and and people in the
business in in the corporate side is
we're all a little bit suspicious.
All we're not just kind of buying into
things just because we're told to buy
into things. you. We all know people who
buy who just believe what they're told,
right? We all have friends who just
believe what they're told. I saw it on
the news. My doctor told me uh you know,
my doctor told me this is bad. My doctor
told me this is good. Blah blah blah.
Guess what? They're not our clients.
They're not our customers. And when
you're looking for clients, you're
looking for customers. You want to weed
those people out. Not that I'm not
saying they're bad people. I hope nobody
hear that's just the way they live their
life. That's fine. We're looking for
people who are a little bit suspicious,
who are a little skeptical, who are a
little cynical, who say, "You know what,
my I've been to 10 different doctors. I
still have my psoriasis. I've been on
this med for the rest for for years and
I still have I'm still hypothyroid." You
know, we're looking for people who smell
a rat, who feel like there's better
ways. And I would encourage distributors
or business people who are looking to
build their business to look for those
people. Not try don't try to present
this message to somebody who is not a
little bit of a freethinker or a little
bit of a critical thinker or or willing
to uh to examine memes, examine beliefs,
examine dogma to dive in to see is it
dogma, is it a belief, is it a meme, or
is it real? Those are our customers and
that's who you want to look
Yes, I agree. And pharmacist Ben, we've
got a lot of questions here. Let's do
>> a lot of things that are um confusing as
far as symptoms go. First one is coming
from Hunter out on YouTube. Says,
"Doctors told my grandma her potassium
is high and to cut back on salads and
spinach. Is that good advice? She's on a
lot of meds and has a lot of dirty blood
issues."
>> Well, there you go. You answered your
own question.
You know, potassium is arguably the most
important electrolyte in the body. I
mean, there's a lot of they're all
important, but potassium is one of the
most important. It's also very strong,
very powerful. That's why doctors don't
want your potassium level to get too
high. However, potassium is addressed is
a potassium levels are addressed by the
kidneys.
If she has dirty blood and she's on a
lot of MET, chances are she's got kidney
problems. Chances are she's got blood
problems. Eliminating salads isn't going
to help. You're still going to have
problems with potassium. You need
potassium and there's potassium in her
body. She's just not clearing it
effectively. So, you know,
as if salads are just potassium,
think of what she's going to be
depriving herself of. What' you say?
Eliminate salads and what else?
>> Salads and spinach,
>> you know. So, you're depriving your body
of you're depriving your body of a
countless a countless uh amount or or
spectrum of anti antioxidants, not to
mention vitamins and fiber and minerals
and everything else. No, it's it's
silliness. Pure silliness to say to
somebody not to eat salad because your
potassium's too high. I can't even
believe they said that. I can only think
that you that's a misunderstanding. That
seems too ridiculous for anybody to say.
>> Well, oh no. I've been I've sat in
doctor's offices where the doctor has
said that pharmacist
>> don't eat salad don't eat
>> more than once
>> really
>> stay away spinach stay away from salads
or leafy greens cruciferous vegetables
you know for for different things but
they can have ice cream and potato chips
and soda
>> yeah okay so I won't have
>> it's like
>> yeah I won't have any salads I'll just
have Chick-fil-A
>> crazy
>> okay
>> all right next um Hunter always ask also
asks asked him about himself. On days I
only eat one meal all at once, do I take
all my pill form supplements all at once
with that meal?
>> Say that again slowly. Do I take all my
>> So wanting to since they're only doing
one meal a day and many of the
>> Do
with meal.
>> Yeah. So do I take all my supplements
with one meal?
>> That's the question.
>> Yeah, that's what I would do depending
on how many they're taking. I mean, if
they're taking like 30 different
supplements, it might be a little
difficult. But yeah, you want to, as a
general rule, take your supplements with
meals. If you take on an empty stomach,
you'll still get some absorption, but
when the when the juices are going, the
digestive juices are going and all the
absorption, all the systems are set up
to absorb, you're going to get better
absorption of your nutrients.
>> Uh, absolutely. Now, NCC Golden says, "I
had tremendous impact when I first
started Youngevity Healthy Digestion
Pack. It was nine days, but it only
lasted maybe two to three months. She
said she
>> What is that? It was nine days, but it
only I don't understand that.
>> I'm not It was nine day, but it only
lasted maybe 3 to 6 months. I'm not
quite sure about that. Um, she was a lot
more
got to a point where she refused pills.
Do I put liquids in daily smoothie?
>> I'm not clear on the question. Do I put
my liquids in a smoothie?
>> So,
yeah. So, now she's wondering because
she This individual is refusing pills
now and wants to know if they can put
liquids into a daily smoothie.
>> Why not? Of course you can. It might not
taste that great. Yeah, it might not
taste great, but
>> but yeah, there's no reason not to do
that. Yeah, liquids are all liquefying
your nutrients is always to your
advantage.
>> Anything you can liquefy is essentially
predigested. It takes a load off the
digestive system, especially if you're
having a chlorhria or low stomach low
stomach acid or you're not making enough
digestive enzymes. Um, liquefying your
liquefying your foods is always the is
it's always to your advantage.
>> Excellent. Now Kathy here in Zoom says,
"I have an ongoing challenge with
heaviness in my legs. kind of like
dragging around tree trunks. She is a
small individual or Mrs. Ben. Um, she
wants to know if you have any ideas.
>> Yeah. Uh, I I haven't heard that
description before, so I don't know what
that means, but it sounds like it could
be a muscle problem. It could be a
problem with with weak muscles, but I
can't tell you specifically because I'd
have to I have to ask a lot of
questions. For example, on any meds, any
health challenges, digestive issues,
blood sugar issues. I'd have to ask a
lot of questions, but it could be my
first guess would be a muscle issue. Get
yourself a rebounder and jump up and
down on a mini rebounder is a mini
trampoline and jump up and down on a
rebounder exercise bike taking and
building up the muscles in your
hamstrings and your and your quadriceps.
That would be that would be my guess,
but I it could be circulatory. I'd have
to ask a lot more questions.
>> All right, thank you so much. So, those
are a couple ideas to try, Kathy. Um,
so here's another question coming out
from YouTube. Does Youngevity use the
best types of calcium and magnesium? So
much info on different types and most
natural
healthy
options.
>> Say that one more time.
Does Youngevity use the best types of
calcium and magnesium?
>> Well, there's different types of calcium
and magnesium. There's different types
of magnesium and calcium. Um,
>> and by types, we mean the second word
after the word magnesium.
>> Magnesium and calcium don't exist on
their own. They're always complexed
um biochemically or chemically with
another molecule. So, you have magn You
don't have magnesium. Nobody there's no
magnesium anywhere. There's magnesium
glycinate. There's magnesium thrienate.
There's magnesium sulfate. That second
word indicates how well that that
mineral, whatever it is, is handled by
the body. So, some forms are handled by
the body better than others. Uh,
longevity carries all the forms. So, if
you're really interested in maximizing
your absorption, look for a form like
lysinate, 3nate. These are forms that
have that are connected to something
that's already that's typically an amino
acid that's in the body. Magnesium
thrienate is bound up with thrienine.
Magnesium glycinate is bound up with
glycine. Magnesium aspartate with a mag
with a aspartic acid. These are amino
acids. Call them amino acid chilates.
And those are typically going to be your
easiest to absorb nutrients or minerals.
the harder ones to absorb are going to
be things like the the sulfates and the
gluconates and the oxides.
So we have we carry them all. The
colloidal magnesium or colloidal
minerals if you will are the instead of
the mineral being attached like this way
like a like a magnet
the uh the minerals surrounded with
organic molecules. So a colloid is a
little bit different. Problem with the
colloid is you're not going to get the
same kind of dose that you would with a
the technical term is a salt form. Salt
form is like magnesium glycinate to take
mag use magnesium as as our as our
example. Magnesium glycinate, magnesium
aspartate, magnesium 3inate, magnesium
oxide, magnesium sulfate, magnesium
gluconate. All of those are salt forms
of magnesium versus colloidal magnesium.
Colloids are very interesting. Colloidal
minerals as we all know we you know
that's what young jevy's all about.
plant derived colloidal minerals.
Colloidal minerals are the mineral
that's surrounded with material from the
plant. That's why they call them plant
derived colloidal minerals.
Surrounded with um with the with the
various protein molecules from the
plant. That colloid
changes the electromagnetics
of the fluids in the body and it changes
the electromagnetics of the cell, the
outside part of the cell. So these
colloids have some really interesting
properties, colloidal minerals, and most
importantly, they're rendered for the
most part non-toxic by this surrounding
colloid or colloal material, but you're
not going to get as much magnesium as
you would in a salt form, techally a
covealent bond or ionic bond depending
on what what kind of mineral um mineral
salt interaction you have. Some of these
things are keelates. They're like the
the amino acids like surround like claws
the uh keilate means claw claws the
mineral. So to answer your question
Jeffy's got everything. The colloids is
what we're known for. But if you really
want a good dose of magnesium you're not
going to get it from magnesium colloid.
The most important thing about the
colloidal minerals is you get all the
minerals. It's more like about getting a
full spectrum of mineral nutrition
rather than one specific mineral. You
want one specific mineral and there are
reasons to get more magnesium, more
calcium, more potassium. For example,
you're going to want to have magnesium
in a in a salt form in a salt form or in
a chilate form as opposed to colloidal
magnesium or whatever mineral we've
talked about.
>> Okay, lots of information there. Thank
you so very much on that. And Kathy
says, "Thank you, Pharmacist Ben. I need
to work on muscle strength."
So,
>> is how old is Kathy older?
>> Um, I think she's in her 70s.
>> Okay. Yeah, you got to work on muscle
strength. That's exactly right.
>> Get yourself an exercise bike.
>> Kathy, I hope it's okay that I exposed
that.
>> So, but she's fantastic. Now, um, so,
okay, before
there was a little bit of confusion in
the way that these were presented, but
night and day difference
when taking when starting on the
Youngevity products, but she says that
it only lasted for 3 to six months. I
personally understand from my own
personal experience is once I started
feeling better,
I started going back to eating the way
that got me sick.
>> Oh,
>> so
>> we do have to make sure that we're
looking at our diet and making sure that
it's not interfering with the absorption
of the nutrition that we are taking.
Because I know whenever I was sick, I
didn't feel like eating. So I ate very
little but then when I started feeling
better I started eating more.
But that's just my personal experience.
Now the next one
is
um wanting to know about liquid
nutrition versus pills.
>> Liquids. Liquids. Liquids. Always
liquids whenever possible.
>> It's not always possible but always
whenever possible always liquids.
particular particularly if you have some
kind of digestive issue.
>> Yes.
And then you had just answered a great
question about magnesium and that
basically follows suit for calcium as
well. Correct.
>> All the minerals. Absolutely. All the
minerals.
>> All right. Let's go to a hand that is up
and we'll go with the first hand that
came up. I think that was AJ. AJ, what
question do you have for pharmacist Ben
today?
>> Pharmacist Ben, how are you?
>> I am good. Nice to see you, AJ.
>> You like my background?
>> Root not fruit.
>> We got
So, uh I I got I got something to talk
to you about on Monday. Okay.
>> It's near and dear. I went to the to the
doctor with my dad and we'll discuss
that on Monday. But today I got a a
question in for from our buddy named
Jesse.
Uh he has been around Youngevity for a
while and he's asking, "Are there any
supplements that may assist someone
fighting cancer, especially if they're
already dealing with tumors and
lesions?"
>> And yes, I'm sorry I don't know enough
more. I know you'd have more detailed
questions for them. Um,
>> yeah, there's a lot there, but just so
you know, cancer shouldn't be regarded
as what do I take for cancer. Cancer is
a is a a disease of overall distress.
Overall cellular distress. So, this idea
of targeting cancer with specific
nutrients, it it really doesn't work
very often unless you're majorly
deficient in one specific nutrient, I
suppose. But really you want to look at
it as a sign of overall biochemical
duress. The entire body is under stress
and then it reflects on the cells. Cells
aren't getting fed. Cells aren't getting
oxygenated. Cells aren't detoxifying
themselves appropriately because the
body is toxic. So the way you want to
look at cancer from a nutritional
standpoint is number one, you want to
make sure you're absorbing your
nutrients. Of course, that means the
digestive system. And number two, you
want to make sure there's no drain on uh
energy via the metabolic system. So you
want to work on point number two, the
blood sugar system. And number three,
you want to give the body a full
spectrum of the mighty 90 essential
nutrients, all 90 of them. You might
want to pay special attention to the
fupoid Z, for example, which helps
support the immune system. Anything with
vitamin C in it, and then restart your
life, betalucan. But you don't want to
think about it like what do I take for
cancer? Because cancer is a systemic
issue. It's the whole system. And this
gets back to what we were talking about
before or or you and I were talking
about I think it was on Monday the
notion that in our culture today in the
world of health in the world of medicine
we focus on individual parts of the body
in a way there are no individual parts
of the body right because everything's
connected. There's no individual
components in the body. The heart is
connected to the spleen and the liver
and the intestine and the brain and the
and the blood and the u bones and
everything else. So this notion of going
to the cardiologist for a heart problem
or going to the pod podiatrist for a
foot problem or going to the
dermatologist for a skin problem or
going to the OB/GYN for a uterine
problem or going to the uh uh to the
urologist for a a bladder problem or
whatever it is. It doesn't. It misses
how the body is put together. That in a
nutshell, at least is one of the reasons
why the medical model is a failure. You
can't focus on one part of the body as
opposed to the entire system. And part
of that is because of just illogic and
because the the pipeline has been built
and nobody wants to rock the boat. But
part of it is because systems theory,
which is the idea of how systems work,
is only about 80 years old or so.
Medicine's hundreds of years old, modern
medicine, you know, and the med
hypocrates because considered the father
of medicine, it's 2100 years old. So to
try to incorporate wisdom from 80 years
ago into an institution that's 2,000
years old, it's really hard to do. But
we have to recognize that it doesn't it
the medical model is not cognizant of
the idea of systems that the body is a
system. That's what naturopathy does.
That's what holistic whole therapy does.
It looks at the body holistically like
it's a whole where every part is
connected to the other part. That's why
we have these three great when we talk
about um on longevity when we talk about
at least when I talk about health and
wellness we talk about three great
points which act as funnel points or or
um gates or control points or leverage
points or bottlenecks. There's different
ways you could put it, but this is one
of the pillars of systems theory that
there's always going to be little places
that you could work that will give you
massive leverage.
And the three points in the three points
in the body that allow you to to to take
advantage of the system nature of the
body, how everything's connected because
you say, "Oh, if everything's connected,
what do I do?" Well, you got these three
points and really only two, and that's
food and that's metabolism. Focus on
food and metabolism. Those are your
major control points for the system
called the human body. You try to work
on the heart
without working on the two control
points. It's not going to work. And and
the proof of is it proof of proof of its
failure
is the fact that it doesn't work. We got
more cardiologists than ever before. The
American Heart Association, we're
spending billions of dollars on heart
disease and everybody we got more heart
disease than ever before. Even though
people may be not dying as much because
we can keep them alive longer, they
still have it because you can't focus on
a part without focusing on the system.
And you can't focus on the system or or
you focus on the system by focusing on
the leverage points. It's almost like
it's too easy because it's so easy. If
you take if you focus on the your
digestive health that includes food and
diet as well as intestinal health
primarily but also the stomach and
pancreas liver gallbladder and the blood
sugar/insulin system the metabolic
system there's no way your body is not
going to improve to the extent that you
improve these two systems. It has to by
definition it has to can't say that
about cardiologists art working with
your heart by going to the doctor's skin
with by going to dermatologist etc. They
can't say that this is guaranteed to
work. I can say if you work on your
digestive system and your blood sugar
system I can guarant and and by working
on it I mean work effectively on it. I
can guarantee you you're going to start
to notice results to the extent that you
participate in uh working on those two
systems. and to the to the extent that
you work on them effectively. You can't
just you can't just, you know, work on
them, you have to work on them
strategically and intelligently. But if
you do it that way, there's no way your
blood pressure is not going to drop.
Your heart function is not going to
improve. Your immune system, your
movement, your skin, your memory, all of
it is not going to get better. It has to
by definition. If you understand the
nature of a system,
>> words never been spoken.
>> Yeah, that's that's a powerful thing. we
can guarantee you results.
>> Thank you.
>> All right. Yes. Thank you. Great, great
information response there. Um, let's go
to the next hand that is up. And Key, go
ahead and unmute yourself.
And while Key is coming on, oh, there
she is.
>> Hi, Ben. How are you, dear?
>> Hi, Keely.
>> Okay. Um, got a couple of short ones, I
hope.
>> Yes.
>> First of all, um, you know, I have a lot
of clients that are having an issue.
They're a little older with swallowing
the EFAs. Do you know of the liquid EFA
that may not
>> There's lots of liquid EFAs, but they
could just stick a pin in them and
squeeze it on their salad or in a
smoothie.
>> Yeah. Cuz I used to take that liquid
flax seed oil and that was pretty easy.
Um,
>> you can do liquid. There's lots of
liquid oils, but if you want to the the
ultimate EFAs, those are that's a nice
little formula. If you want to if you
want to stay on the ultimate EFAs, you
can stick a pin in them or you can take
some scissors and cut them and squeeze
them into a smoothie.
>> Okay, great. I know that Becca chews
them, but that's just not an option.
>> You chew them. You really do.
>> Yes, I do.
>> Yeah,
>> I tried doing that. That doesn't work
for me.
>> All right. I hadn't heard that. Okay. Um
do you what are your thoughts about
after somebody has built um and this is
my um oldest son. He had rebuilt his
bone matrix up by 37%. Okay. So he's
back to normal.
>> Doing what?
>> How did he do it?
>> Actually all on glucel. The glucagel
plus the MSM and the collagen. So this
is your son.
>> Yes.
>> How old's your son?
>> 46 years old. He um got one of the jabs
and that was the result of it.
>> Okay.
>> The loss of the bone matrix. So um he's
totally rebuilt. What would you say
would be the maintenance that you would
keep?
>> Exercise. Exercise.
>> Exercise.
>> Well, no, there's more. There's more.
So, the bones are made up, everybody
knows the bones are made of calcium,
right? But they're not made of calcium.
They have calcium in them, but they're
really made of collagen.
>> And then calcium, the little dry uh
calcium fills in the holes, if you will.
It's like a matrix. And then calcium,
other minerals, not just calcium, but
you know, strontium, zinc, magnesium.
There's a lot of minerals that kind of
harden the bone. So the most important
thing you do for the bone number one is
build the collagen. That's the most
important. And so people are taking
calcium for their bones, you'd be much
better off using vitamin C and collagen
peptides, beyond tangy tangerine,
healthy bone and joint pack, etc. So um
building the matrix or keeping the
matrix built um is a protein issue,
collagen specific. Then there are the
minerals. But here's the thing, this is
really important for people dealing with
bone issues, especially given our topic
today. bone, weak bones, frail bones,
osteoporosis, osteopenia, whatever you
want to call it,
is a symptom.
It's not the disease. It's not a
disease. Osteoporosis is not a disease.
It's a sign. It's a symptom. It's a
symptom that the bones are degrading.
The bones are
a repository
of alkaline material. And when the body
becomes acidic,
calcium will leech out of the bones. the
bones will become weak as a response to
the acid to try to alkalize the acid. So
weak bones are a sign of blood toxicity.
Chronically weak bones are a sign of
blood toxicity. Now there could also be
nutritional deficiencies and that's why
it's always important to make sure
you're using getting your protein, your
collagen peptides, um healthy bone and
joint pack, etc. Glucagel caps, all of
that. But you also want to make sure
that the system is pristine,
particularly the blood. If the blood is
acidic, and acid's a sign of waste,
waste that's not being cleared. If the
blood is acidic, the bones are going to
become weak, no matter how much
nutrition you're taking. So, in addition
to exercise and nutritional supplements,
your son needs to make sure that he's
systemically healthy. So, if he has
blood sugar issues, that could cause the
blood to become acidic. If he has
digestive issues, that can cause the
blood to become acidic. has respiratory
issues that can cause the blood to
become acidic. All of these can lead to
acidity in the blood, low pH in the
blood, which will weaken the bones no
matter how much nutrition he's taking.
So, nutrition, yes. Exercise, yes, too.
And then also make sure he's taking care
of his overall systemic health.
>> Okay. So, bottom line is I can draw the
conclusion that I can take him off of
all of the MSM and the glucel.
>> I wouldn't Why would you do that?
>> I don't know. That's what I'm asking.
for like a maintenance dose.
>> No, no, keep them on everything. MSM's
not just for your bone. MSM is not just
for bones. Sulfur is one of the most
important electrical elements in the
body. It's not just for bones.
>> Max levels. I mean,
>> max level. I mean, he doesn't have to.
We take You can take less, but why not?
Why? It's cheap. It's non-toxic. I would
take max levels. I take I take three
grams of I've taken three grams a day of
MSM for years. And then um and then also
um the gluccog caps is another one of
those nutrients that or another one of
those supplements that's
multifunctional. Gluccogel caps are
important for your blood vessels. The
glucco gel caps can help your body uh
can uh prevent um uh clo uh clogging or
um the word I'm looking for uh
blockages.
How would how would the gluccoel how
would the glucco gel caps
>> help prevent blockages in the heart or
in the arteries?
Because the glucco gel caps
>> what
>> they do they fluidize the blood. They
they do fluidize the blood. That's true.
But they also strengthen the blood
vessels. The the arteries remember the
arteries become weakened with
nutritional deficiencies and toxicities
and lack of oxygen. So st and that's
when cholesterol deposits and um and
calcium plaques that's when they all
start to become problematic and that's
when they lead to blockages. So you want
to make sure your vessels are strong.
The more toxicity you have in the blood
the stickier the blood is you know we
talk about that a lot but the more
damage you're going to have to the
vessels. Once the vessels become damaged
that's when the repair mechanisms kick
in. And when the repair mechanisms kick
in chronically, not just once or twice,
but chronically, that's where you get
your blockages. So the gluccoel caps are
not just important for the answer to for
keley. The gluccoel caps will help him
with his heart
>> and his vascule and his blood in
addition to helping him with his uh
>> Yeah, understood. I I'm just going to
reduce him from he's taking 18 a day. So
I'm gonna I'm gonna back them back down
in half in half.
>> Take as many as you want. They're
they're non-toxic. You can take as many
as you want or as little as you want. um
given that
>> but you see what I'm saying how these
nutrients are good for lots of other
things. Oh yeah, absolutely. And then
the only other thing is a show idea.
There's a lot of controversy out there
on peptides. I hope that you cover that
some point in time.
>> Peptides for the scanner.
>> Not today maybe, but sometime.
>> Injectable peptides.
>> Yes.
>> All right. So in and we can talk about
but real quick, they're not in the same
class as essential nutrients. Essential
peptides
tell the cell what to do. Now
fortunately the cells are not stupid. So
they're just not going to do it. and
their peptides are not as as potent as
drugs. So, it's not quite it's not quite
as problematic as pharmarmacology, but
they're still in the same category as
drugs as opposed to nutrients. Remember,
nutrients set the table.
Nutrients give the body the option to do
what it wants to do. Peptides tell the
cell what to do. Now, they're not as
strong as drugs. Drugs poison the cell.
Peptides don't poison the cell. So, the
cell can still either say yay or nay
with a peptide. doesn't have that option
with drugs. So, they're not quite like
drugs. You can maybe think of them like
a like right in the middle. They're not
essential. Nobody has a peptide
deficiency. People have lots of nutrient
deficiencies obviously, but they're not
as toxic or as as um as a pharmac
say toxic as poisonous as a drug would
be.
>> All right.
>> Thank you. We'll see you.
>> Thank you. Thank you, Keely. Great
question. And I'm so glad, folks. Did
you catch that? Had a depletion of the
bone matrix and has increased at 37%
using the nutrition.
That's significant.
>> Really significant.
>> That's fantastic.
So, all right, couple more questions.
And we also have another hand. Um, let's
take the live person. I want the live
person.
>> The live person
>> because then I got to go. Well,
>> the others are live, too. Just
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
Um, so first question is, do you know
any side effects from two gram
milligrams, I think, or is that two
grams of lion's mane supplement?
>> I got that one.
>> Probably two grams. Um, two milligrams
wouldn't be very much. Um, yeah, I
assume it's two grams. Now, there it's
pretty non-toxic. Some people have
problems with mushrooms, though, so you
got to be a little bit careful. But
that's pretty much non-toxic. Two grams
is not a lot. Two grams is like half a
teaspoon full.
>> Okay. And then um you were talking
earlier about the bladder and having you
know our body is not a bunch of little
systems. It's one system together. The
question is how can a woman strengthen
her bladder? So how do we support the
whole body?
>> Kaggles the the what do you mean what do
you mean by strengthen like she's
incontinent like in for incontinence? Is
that what you're talking about?
>> Well that's a possibility. Kaggels also
connective tissue building.
>> Okay.
>> The connective tissue in the bladder is
very underappreciated. In fact, there's
a connective tissue there's a there's a
symptom a miserable symptom that's due
to connective tissue deterioration or
that follows connective tissue
deterioration in the bladder um and in
the the plumbing system we'll say called
interstatial cyitis. Have you heard of
this?
>> I have.
>> And no no medical there's no medical
strategy for treating that. because it's
not once again it's not where you see
the problem you know it's the the
problem is not as miserable as it is you
know the pain is not the the the
constant urination all of that is
secondary to or follows deterioration of
the connective tissue the connective
tissue the relationship between the
connective tissue and the health of the
urethra and the bladder and the the
plumbing system as I say is very
underappreciated
and if you have any kind of bladder
problem you want to be focusing on the
connective tissue it's not going to
happen instantly because it takes a
while for the connective tissue to build
And also things like sugar and smoking
and drugs and or diet will compromise
connective tissue building. So you got
to take care of that end of it. And you
also want to do things like the healthy
bone and joint pack to take care of
connective tissue. So for her, I'd be
building connective tissue and also
muscle. How do you build muscle? Kaggel
exercises. You know what a kaggel is?
>> That's where you tighten everything up,
hold it, let it go. Tighten everything
up.
>> Yes.
>> And then even when when you're sitting
and urinating, stopping the flow.
Tighten it up, stop it,
>> and then let it go again. the muscle
that you use to stop urinating, you want
to exercise that. That can be exercised.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. Fantastic. And let's go. I
know. Do you have time for AJ?
>> AJ, what's up?
>> Um, somebody messaged me and and asked,
"How do we know if the blood is acidic?"
>> Um,
if you're sick, you know the blood is
acidic or it's not necessarily acidic.
It's less alkaline than it needs to be.
It doesn't have to be full-blown
acidity. your blood pH is tightly
tightly controlled. 7.38.
If it's 7.37, it's not acidic. It's I
guess it's relatively acidic. It's not
technically acidic, but it's more acidic
than it should be. Uh if you're
symptomatic, that's how you know. Now,
you can do things like a saliva test or
urine test. You get a pH paper and
that'll give you a rough estimate.
>> What if you're sneezing?
>> Just you have constant sneezing. Well,
if you're just sneezing in general, does
that mean you're acidic?
>> No, not necessarily. Could be have some
irritation in your respiratory tract or
in your in your nostrils or sinuses.
>> So, there's no outward sign
>> for blood acidity. No, not there's no
outward sign. You can infer it by things
like osteoporosis or or immune problems
or any kind of degenerative disease. you
can kind of infer it or you can have
your urine uh urine test done or or a
urine pH test or a blood or a saliva pH
test and that will give you kind of like
an ext kind of aversion but you can't
really test the blood unless you go into
the blood I suppose take some blood out
but for the most part it's simp it's
look for your symptoms if you're
symptomatic assume you have acidic blood
it's chronically symptomatic I should
say
>> awesome and AJ go ahead go ahead and
stay up here and if to get get the other
co-hosts on screen. I know you got to
go. Thank you so much for a great
pharmacist Friday.
>> Thank you.
>> We greatly appreciate you. We'll see him
next Friday, but don't forget Mondays as
there is pharmacist Ben bites with coach
AJ. So super excited to be able to have
pharmacist Ben twice a week to help you
as an individual learn what you can do
and coming from a pharmacist education
and point of view to help yourself. So,
thank you AJ for putting that together.
Uh, just giving us another opportunity
to learn, learn, learn. And I want to
give a thank you and shout out to each
of the individuals we have here today.
And even those that aren't able to make
it, we want to send out our love to them
as they do so much even when they're not
here on the show. And my executive
production manager, Ruth Ellen. Thank
you so much as she gets on with me an
hour early just to make sure we got
everything going correctly. So thankful.
And Nancy says, "Grateful to Ben Fuches
and the team." Thank you, Nancy.
Appreciate your comment there.
Um and we also have Albert joining us
from South Africa sometimes in the
middle of the night when he should be
sleeping. His dedication to help others
help themselves and to learn himself
is apparent in him being here with us
each and every day. So, thank you so
much Albert for all you do as he is the
one to thank for letting you into the
zoom folks. And we also have Phyllis who
is uh filling the shoes of Marilyn and
also bringing in questions and putting
them so I can read them. So she's like
double duty today. Thank you so much
Phyllis as a pioneer of the what we
share here on the young on the daily
with doc show. Um, and again, thank you
AJ. And we have Coach Rod on with us as
he is out on the different platforms
keeping an eye on things and bringing
questions in as well. So, and as AJ
said, nobody can fill Marilyn's shoes.
That's for sure. She is. Yeah, because
Phyllis brought her own shoes. Well,
thank you so much everybody for joining
us here on Daily with Doc and Becca. My
name is Becca Dukes and again as a
certified naturopathic practitioner and
certified holistic health coach through
the Institute of Holistic Health which
pharmacist Ben mentioned earlier and if
you want more information on that go to
coach.dwithdoc.com
and you'll get more information on that
and click that enroll and you'll see
that they also offer payment plans. So,
not only is it affordable to start, you
can do payment plans to make it even
more so. Again, that's
coach.dailywithdoc.com.
And folks, if you were referred to this
program by somebody specific, get back
with them. So, so important because they
took the time and cared enough about
you. Get back with them with any
questions. They're going to be your
primary source. Now, if you found this
program all on your own and you've never
spoken to anybody about the show or
about pharmacist bin or about longevity
and you do want to connect with a
certified holistic health coach, please
call 8559
9493377.
Again, that's 855
3377.
and you will be connected with one of
our team uh here for the Daily with Doc
and Becca show. And AJ, what did I
forget?
>> You didn't forget a thing. But did you
mention that Youngevity's got several
products with lion's mane mushroom in
it?
>> I did not mention that, but that is so
very true.
>> Yeah,
>> very true. You got the coffee. You got
the ultimate microbiome, the apple cider
vinegar gummies,
>> hot chocolate,
>> the hot I mean, and then don't forget
about your rise and restore. I mean,
come on. We got Lion's mane all over the
place.
>> Absolutely we do. We've got pretty much
everything in a form that the body can
actually utilize because it's got the
co-actors and it's in a form that's
absorbable. So, you can't go wrong. So,
get back with the person that shared
this program with you or give us a call
855-9493377.
And if you have a question or prefer to
go through, email questions with an
sungity.
No, no, no, no, no. They don't have that
email. Questions dailywithdoc.com.
Again, that's questions with an
sdailywithdoc.com,
which dailywithdoc.com again is a
sponsor of today's show. So, until next
time, thanks for joining us everybody.
Have a fantastic weekend and we'll see
you next time on Daily with Doc and
Becca.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, four
post-doates in pathology, naturopathic
doctor.
Thank you.